this is what would happen if you jumped  into a pool full of liquid mercury  liquid mercury is a shiny metal that's  constantly in a liquid state in theory  you could fill up a pool with it but  could you jump in and swim well not  exactly if you jumped in from a diving  board you'd be met with a thud rather  than a satisfying splash that's because  mercury is 13 times more dense than  water and substantially heavier and  walking into the pool would be like  standing on watery jello that would be  incredibly difficult to balance on not  only that but the liquid mercury would  cause severe burns and irritation  wherever it touched your skin and the  longer you leave it on your skin the  worse it gets prolonged exposure to  liquid mercury would result in mercury  poisoning and over time this could  result in vision loss speech  difficulties and a lack of coordination  oh and also if you stayed in the pool  long enough you'd pass out from the  fumes and die  so